we have some breaking news for you  you're looking at a live picture of a  major building collapse in the East  Village  scarlet food our breaking news desk has  more scarlet what can you tell us yeah  this is a building collapse on Second  Avenue the address is 125 second Avenue  a 7th Street and st. Mark's Place it's  in downtown Manhattan and we have a 30  people injured according to the New York  Post so this is a building collapse I'm  still looking through and seeing that  they're on Twitter there multiple EMS  EMS buses are rushing over as well you  can see the smoke billowing into the air  we'll continue to keep you posted we  don't know the cause of this just yet  the latest count is 30 people injured in  this building collapse no word on  fatalities once again in downtown  Manhattan on second Avenue near 7th  Street and st. Mark's Place